I'm back on the microphone today after
doing something I've never done in my
entire life I'm getting ready turned 58
years old I started working 40 hours a
week one or more when I was 18 years old
so is that 40 years I think so
I've never taken three weeks off in my
life taking two weeks off but I've never
taken three two weeks was very hard
three weeks is even harder and the
reason was SWI we have a saying in our
house SWI sharon wants it and so
Sharon's Christmas present was she
wanted to go to Africa and do the Safari
thing and see the animals and take
pictures and all that kind of stuff and
so we've been gone three weeks there
which was an incredible iconic thing
it's living like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else and I did both while I was there by
the way I'm an outrageous tipper in
situations like that where a a ver egde
household income might be as low as
2,000 American dollars a year $100 tip
is a big deal and so I like making big
deals out of things so we had a blast
while we were there it was a lot of fun
and yes there's a four-year-old kid
inside of every one of us when you see
animals up close like that it's and the
guys going well yeah you're 58 you want
to know that but I mean it's it was fun
it was really iconic and loved Africa
loved the people of Africa and it never
never ceases to amaze me when I travel
that I meet people that I love and I see
how Great America is at the same time
it's not just a patriotic statement it's
just hard to prosper with the level of
corruption that some of these countries
deal with it's hard to prosper when
there's no orderly transition of power
when the transmission of power means you
have to kill the entire ruling family
and slaughter half the army in order to
transition power every time you do it
it's very difficult to have economic
stability and
part of the result of that is extreme
poverty there's consequences to your
decisions when you make choices and when
I make choices and when governments make
choices and the entire people group
decide to transition things with
violence or demonstrations or whatever
and that's how they want to effect
change it destabilizes everything there
are consequences to our choices same
thing with your debt right same thing
with your ability to build wealth and
there there are in countries so we came
home and if you don't know I've got five
grandkids under the age of four which is
pure awesomeness and we had grandkid
withdrawals so we had them all at the
lake house this weekend and we have five
under four that means that at any given
time at least one of them is in full
meltdown at any given time and so one of
the other ones the three-year-old looked
over and at one of her cousins was
getting corrected for the meltdown and
she said so-and-so's having consequences
if three years old she's figured out
there are consequences and yet entire
governments have not figured that out
and some of you they call yourselves
grown-ups have not figured that out and
sometimes I've not figured that out
because if I had an entire bag of
chocolate chip cookies there's
consequences it's called a big belly you
know and yeah I got all that and that's
a true story
so we all got it don't we but I mean
even in spite the fact we know there's
consequences we still do stupid stuff
don't we all of us and this show is
about doing a little less stupid
recognizing that were grownups and we
need to do consequences we need to
recognize that there's consequences that
we don't get them negative consequences
positive consequences if you save $100 a
month through your working lifetime
you'll be a millionaire when you retire
if you do that in a good growth stock
mutual fund and decent Roth IRA hello
it's consequences you can retire and
everyday millionaire its consequences
you're not spending everything you make
you positive consequences right
and so let's work on our cart let's work
on our choices make positive choices so
we have positive consequences because
what you plant you're going to grow
there is a cause and effect thing in the
universe God calls it in the Bible
sowing and reaping when you plant wheat
don't be shocked if wheat grows don't
plant weed and go where's the corn you
planted wheat doofus you're gonna get
wheat what you plant in your life is
what you're going to get back to choices
that you make whether you're a
government a continent a family and
individual is your family stable enough
to prosper are you doing with so much
toxicity and dysfunction inside the
family that you can't possibly prosper
you know sometimes people don't have
dysfunction because of lack of
prosperity they have lack of prosperity
because of dysfunction lack of character
which causes bad choices sometimes some
not people are poor because they've been
oppressed and beat up on and had stuff
taken away from them you can definitely
see that in other countries when you go
there but if you want a place where you
make good choices you get good results
and bad choices you get bad results and
you have the freedom to do so and you
have the freedom to just decide today to
change you cannot beat the United States
of America I've been on all of them I
mean I'm not every single country in the
world but I've seen all forms of
government and I've seen the
consequences of those forms of
government on the people that supposedly
quote unquote live under them again I've
never been anywhere in the world that I
just didn't like the people I like the
people everywhere I go I feel really bad
for them and how corrupt violent and
dysfunctional their governments are
sometimes and oh I know you like to say
we're corrupt here and we're
dysfunctional here how many of you ain't
got nothing I mean we're not even a a
flea on the back of a dog compared to
these other people it's unbelievable
the worst corruption we've ever
experienced in America is not even
noticeable in comparison in contrast so
can we do better here yeah can you do
better in your house yeah can I do
better with my chocolate chip cookies
yeah bet so let's all get on board let's
all start doing a little better let's
all know that there's consequences to
our choices and we have the freedom and
the power to make choices ready set go
oh look at that you can just decide
can't you you can get the scissors out
place them across that stupid credit
card and cut it up you can get out a
piece of paper and do a budget in about
20 minutes you can jump on every dollar
and do your budget for free in about 20
minutes ready set go
make choices that give you the
consequences you want because you're
gonna live in the consequences of not
making choices or making bad ones are
making good ones it's gonna be one of
the three darling she might as well do
it on purpose
that's what we're here for sure is good
to be back welcome everybody we want to
help you you've done something stupid
this is your place we'll help you
we're not gonna endorse your stupidity
will walk with you out of it though